This is how it works, right.
So I've got my one image and
my other image,
which is why they're called image 1 and
image 2, all right.
And, the first thing we're going to do
is we're going to build what are called
Gaussian pyramids, all right.
And that's illustrated like this.
So it's Gaussian pyramid of image one.
Well we'll talk more extensively in
a minute about how you might go about
building those pyramids.
This is just mostly so
you understand what is going on.
So now I have these reduced
pyramids at the top level.
Remember I have that very blurry picture
that actually only has a small number of
pixels in it and the motion between
them is actually much smaller.
And that's shown here, right?
So here, it says our u is ten.
So that's saying,
let's suppose the shift is ten pixels,
at the lowest level.
Well when I cut it in half,
it becomes five.
Then it becomes two and a half.
Then it becomes one and a quarter.
I can keep going.
So this is how I reduce the amount
of motion that's present.
So because I've reduced
the amount of motion,
I can first run Lukas-Kanade
between those coarsest level.
And I might do the iterative thing,
that's the thing we looked at
last time where I set a plane,
estimate it, shift it a little bit,
estimate it, shift it a little bit.
Keep doing til i, til I converge.
So that will map the motion between
the very reduced image 1 and
the very reduced image 2.
Right, so I can, I can compare that.
I can find the motion between them.
The question then is, what do I do next?
Well what I have to do is,
I have to go from the coarser
to the next finer level, okay?
And what's written here is warp and
upsample, all right?
We're going to go through the details
of that, but basically the way you can
think about this is,
I compared something at a coarse level.
Then I know, okay,
if I were to double up this image and
double up that image, I would have
to double up the motion field.
I would also have to double the,
the, the amount I'm moving.
We'll do that algorithm in a minute.
But I could apply that to the next
level and what that will do is,
that will get me the next level
very close to the second image.
At that level and I could run Lucas and
Kanade again, and then I can iterate and
run that over again and
eventually get the entire motion field.